[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in carson palmer uh former
nfl quarterback uh how would you respond
to that if you're jared goff when your
coach says that after a loss
well when when jared was a young
quarterback and just kind of getting
into the game and figuring things out
like i was you learn at a very young age
playing this position that when you win
you're the hero when when you lose
you're the bum and
there's too much put on you when you win
and there's too much put on you when you
lose but i think the most important
thing that he said it was at the very
end when he said he needs help because
he needs help i mean they can't stop
anybody on defense offensive lines been
an issue they don't really have many
playmakers behind him in the running
back position or outside of him at the
wide receiver spot so
when you lose things get get heaped on
you but there's no doubt jared goff
needs some help have you ever been
called out by your coach in a press
conference
oh yeah oh yeah it happens all the time
i mean most times when you lose they say
the quarterback needs to play better and
obviously i think
jared be the first to tell you he needs
to play better but there's no doubt i
mean with with his skill set he needs
help he needs playmakers around him
because he doesn't have very many
explain to me the chargers got all this
love last week and then they go to
baltimore and that was not an inspiring
effort like uh
as much as we should compliment the
ravens lamar jackson and their defense
but the chargers it felt like okay let's
see what you got national stage and uh
they did not produce why
they're not quite there yet they're not
completely ready to be one of the
premier teams in the afc they've got
some really nice nice things about them
they got their a good young quarterback
they got a bose of brother down there on
the defensive line derwyn james is an
animal and on the back end a defensive
back
you know at the end of the day are you
ready to you know
all the hype you've been getting as a
charger are you ready to go into
baltimore in one of the most hostile
environments
and put out and show out and and prove
that you deserve to be talked about as
one of the better teams in the afc they
answered that question for us they went
to baltimore and got blown out they're
not quite there yet but i'm not giving
up on that team i cannot wait to watch
them how they respond this week is
really telling of what kind of team that
is what kind of leadership they have and
who their head coach is
cardinals go to cleveland it banged up
cleveland team but they they dominated
them that doesn't feel like everybody's
all in on the cardinals yet what do you
think is the big uh reason why there's a
hold out
well it's it's then you know it's the
opposite of what we just said about
about the chargers can you go into
baltimore
and win will can you know can the
cardinals 4-0 team
go out east and and go into ohio and
beat the browns and they beat them
decisively it wasn't close i mean i know
that team was beat up but the cardinals
have heard all that kind of west coast
bias
all the real teams are out there on the
east coast they went in to the east
coast went into ohio and got a win that
that you know they should have won they
were playing against uh a team that was
beat up the cardinals were extremely
healthy so i mean it you know it's the
same thing we just said about the
chargers if you're for real arizona
go to ohio and and leave no doubt on the
field who the best team is and they did
that they are for real
everybody needs to respect that team
they're 5-0 for a reason
you know they haven't started off
against some weak teams they beat some
good teams especially this last week
going into cleveland against the team
you know is going to run the ball try to
run the ball down your throat they went
in there they they looked really good
and they look like the best team in the
league right now
it feels like there's uh the nfc is top
heavy you got five teams that are at
least five in one you got the cardinals
being undefeated
dallas wins put up big numbers
but they allowed new england to take
them into overtime what do you take away
from dallas's win
a win is a win especially when you go
into new england i mean yeah we'd like
to walk out with you know a two or three
score lead but a win is a win that the
best team most the time at the end of
the day especially when you go to
overtime finds a way to win and i don't
care if it was close i don't care how
many points they scored or how many
points the defense gave up dallas is for
real they've got a really nice division
for them they're sitting in at a good
spot in a good division um i just think
they are for real and they're going to
make a run this year did you ever find
yourself in a competition within a
competition against that quarterback on
the other team during a game of
matching them to do your your part you
know the stats
you you tried not to um but especially i
don't know if you're referring to baker
mayfield and kyler murray playing
against each other former teammates at
oklahoma
but no doubt i mean every quarterback
wants to go in and throw for a little
bit more yards have a little bit higher
completion percentage and and have a
better qb rating so um you can try to
block that out and you can try to say
you know it's just about our team
playing well and winning but i think you
know at the at the root of every
competitive uh tussle between two teams
i think down there deep both those
quarterbacks want to have a better
statistical day without a doubt but did
you find you did that when you faced
roethlisberger or you've faced you know
whoever brady
whoever you were facing on a regular
basis semi-regular basis
absolutely i would go in the locker room
you know hopefully after a win and i
would get the stat sheet right before i
went into my press conference post game
and i would just double check and see
where numbers were so i i think it's
pretty normal i would i would assume
just about every quarterback in the
league does that
yeah um
but can you could did you ever have a a
great game in a loss like
can you can you separate what you did as
opposed to what your team did
no i mean at the end of the day
quarterbacks are the only position and
and really head coaches the only guys
that are judged on wins and losses not
on how many tackles they had or what
their defense finished you know
categorically at the end of the season
it's about wins and losses as a
quarterback you're a judge so you know
at the end of the day what matters is
the win and then after you get the win
you can you know personally look at your
own statistics and make sure that that
you had better numbers than your
opponent but
it's about the win no doubt
what the hell happened to the miami
dolphins
but they're who they're who we thought
they were i mean a lot of people got you
know jumped on the bandwagon got excited
about that team got excited about brian
flores and you know he's the first you
know bill belichick understudy to go on
and have success
he hadn't had success yet i mean that
that team was really sexy preseason
because they had all the draft picks
they had all the cap space they're still
not a very good football team
you you know they got a gift win against
new england now they've lost five in a
row then you lose to jacksonville in
london and
they don't have their first round pick
philadelphia has that
i mean that's
that's a tough situation to be and then
i don't even know if they're all in on
tua uh because
right they're not
yeah they're simply not i mean they
thought that deshawn watson trade i
think
it looks like it and it seems like
everything was pointing towards them
being able to acquire desean this off
season obviously that didn't happen
because of all the off the field stuff
going on in deshawn's life but um you
know i think they realized pretty early
on that that tua might not be the right
guy that's why you saw ryan fitzpatrick
playing early on um and now you're
seeing some real struggles so i think
that deshaun watson trade uh they were
eyeing that they were hoping that
happened it didn't so i mean they can
have all the first round picks and and
they can have all the cap room but if
you don't have your
your qb of the future then you're still
going to be constantly looking for him
and wanting him trying to trade for him
trying to draft him whatever it may be
in the future of miami but i just don't
see tua being the guy there long term
he's carson palmer former nfl
quarterback who joins us every monday
the difference between college and pros
we hear this a lot in in college you
throw to the guy who's open in the pros
you have to throw a guy open
explain that difference and how long did
it take
for you to be able to understand that
concept
yeah in college i mean you have the the
ability to sit back and wait for a
receiver to get open and then throw it
so that the receiver once he gets the
top of his route and breaks in or out
can get his eyes back to the quarterback
and see the ball coming at him that's
because in college most guys in the back
end run four five to four six
40 yard dash and so when you get to the
nfl just about everybody on the back end
runs four three two four four which
means
all of those windows are smaller the
ball can't be in the air for longer for
very much longer because defensive backs
are closing on it so you have to know
that your receiver is getting up to 10
yards and he's breaking in and you need
to throw that ball when he's about seven
or eight yards past the line of
scrimmage into his route so that when he
rounds those last two yards and is
coming in he will not see the ball come
off your fingertips he will turn his
head to the quarterback and the ball
will be about halfway to him
in the nfl and in college you know that
that small difference in a 40-yard dash
time means those windows close extremely
fast and guys are only open for really a
very short period of time and in college
you see you know you watch oklahoma play
you see guys running you know wide open
but naked down the middle of the field
you just do not see that at the nfl
level that's the difference between when
you have guys that run 4-3 in college
and you're playing against guys that run
four six once you get the nfl
everybody's running four three four four
so those windows and those butt naked
receivers aren't running wide open down
the middle of the field
that that's just that's a football term
right butt naked
but naked yeah every coach uses it oh
they do
you can use it too dan yeah okay all
right so give me another term i haven't
heard
uh
that's clean
no um
that's a tough one what do you mean
that's clean
that's you know family friendly yeah but
like i'm assuming this is disney-ish
aren't we on espn disney no no we're not
no we're not we're not on we're on fire
but yeah peacock there you go butt naked
open um
or or if we're on p peacock can i say
wide ass open yeah you can sure why not
that works too
i think that's a show on peacock white
ass open yeah
you know you start to look at dak
prescott and you come off that injury
and we talked about this before where
you can't think about the injury and it
seems like
he's pretty comfortable in
whatever i don't like him throwing 50
times it feels like they're a whole lot
better when they run more than they pass
but what did you make of dak prescott
i think he's throwing the ball better
than i've seen him throw the ball in the
first five years of his career
he threw on the run
working his way up to the line of
scrimmage a high angle corner route that
was one of the most beautiful balls i've
seen through this season
you're not seeing any lingering issues
in his or his confidence any lingering
issues confidence wise and stepping up
in the pocket moving around i've seen
him break numerous tackles he's not you
know
gingerly moving around
um you know he's not overly concerned
you can tell you know as you know year
one post surgery there's always going to
be naturally some some things holding
you back but as far as when he hits the
grass and it's sunday he looks really
confident in in the stability of his leg
he looks really confident in the guys
around him he's playing with a smile on
his face i mean there's no more pressure
than a quarterback's playing under than
than dak prescott in dallas for the
cowboys so i mean he just looks he just
looks back he looks healthy it's really
fun to watch
did people talk like this whole taunting
rule and and how players respond did did
players did you ever taunt
when you were in the nfl
not really i mean it was talking trash
you know the that the fun part of
talking trash um is they're trying to
kind of wipe that off the game um you
know you think back to like one of my
favorite players to watch ever was
philip rivers phillip rivers would only
be moving backwards if he were playing
in today's game i mean
he talked more than anybody and and i
guess you can call it taunted but it was
just talking trash and it was part of
the game it was fun uh back in my day i
mean chad johnson chad ocho cinco sent a
box of pepto-bismol to cleveland before
we were playing cleveland he sent us the
deep is that taunting can you get
can you get a 15-yard penalty on
thursday if you send pepto-bismol
to the to the cleveland
browns it's just getting out of control
what's philip rivers saying on the field
it's all clean i've never heard him
curse i have yet to hear him curse but
he's just having fun that's the game
you're allowed to talk you you used to
be allowed to talk you know there was
always
um some razzing going back and forth and
now it looks like it feels like they're
trying to get rid of it um but i don't i
don't think i think i think philip would
have a number of fines going into weeks
uh is it six now week seven seven
but so he would just say you know you
can't stop us or you know you can't you
know gosh dang it you can't sack me or
yeah or don't try to bring that will
free safety blitz on me and he throws it
the other way for a touchdown i mean he
was always constantly talking and
that's what got him going and it pissed
off guys on the other side of the ball
but that's just that's the way that i
grew up playing football in the game i i
knew today's game they're just trying to
get rid of it and it is what it is okay
but when a guy sacks you and he stands
over you
and then walks over you like that always
bothered me that's where i want to like
reach my hand up
and you know hit you in the groin if you
step over me
did you yeah that that's that's really
disrespectful at the end of the day
you're getting into being a respectful
player by you know i i don't think
there's anything disrespectful about
talking trash but when you stand over a
player or spike the ball in their face
or do the allen iverson tyronn liu where
he walked over him after he hit that
three-pointer like that that's starting
to cross the line of being disrespectful
i think that's what they're trying to
get out of the way and get out of the
game unfortunately
when the league decides to get rid of
something they decide to get rid of it
entirely so you're not allowed to talk
to any other you know any other player
in the field that's not one of your team
members
they're just trying to wipe it out of
the game unfortunately great to talk to
you as always carson thanks for joining
us
thanks dan that's carson palmer his
weekly appearance during the nfl season
brought to you by our partner level
select cbd looking for next level relief
visit levelselectcbd.com